[Music]
what is the cure for crippling anxiety
benzos benzos
yes yes yes oh i wish it was that simple
i would like i would like john to
expand on anxiety where it comes from
what it is
the fake cures that don't actually cure
it
i i can tell you for me the only cure
for when i get anxiety i tend to be more
anxious than someone like ryan is
intense physical exercise there's a hill
right by my house
uh and it's on a main street and i'll
just go running up it as fast as i can
and by the time i'm at the top of that
hill i'm so worn out i don't have room
for anxiety anymore but let's talk about
before we talk about tammy's question
the cure for crippling anxiety where
does anxiety come from
uh i think we've pathologized anxiety to
a large degree so whenever i had this
conversation i want everyone to picture
a bell curve and there is way outside on
the long tails of either side of this
bell curve there's
true neurological issues there's true
you know hormone imbalances things like
that so putting those aside right
anxiety is really just an alarm system
that's all it is and it is just letting
you know
most of the time you're disconnected
you're out of relationship with people
in your community you found yourself
alone and if you think back a couple of
thousand years and you woke up on the
plains of nebraska or kansas and your
tribe had left you you're probably gonna
die right you're gonna get eaten by
something you're gonna
die starvation you're gonna die of
exposure
we are co-regulated physiologically we
are designed to be in community and
relationship with other people in a room
together doing life right and so when
our body recognizes that's not the case
it will sit on the alarm right or we're
in a situation we're not safe we're an
abusive relationship we were abused and
our body is recognizing that guy looks
like or she looks like and it is letting
us know hey you're not safe or the third
one is we're in a situation where we
can't control the outcome the nerd word
is autonomy right we don't have autonomy
for our next own decision
and all it is is our bodies just trying
to get our attention and in the last 25
years
can i back out for a second let's do it
yeah so
if you look at all human history and
progress it's beautiful because we're
trying to solve for
um the next best thing right we're gonna
make a little bit better plow make a
little a horse let's breed that horse so
that would make a little bit stronger
horse so we can do a little bit more
yard work or
you know have a little bit uh do it a
little bit faster
that's all great and then technology
caught up and passed our ability to
think through what we were doing and so
we begin to solve for comfort rapidly
and i love leather seats one day i'm
going to get a car that's got them it's
going to be awesome
i like air conditioners i like heaters i
like all the stuff right yeah
yeah you're from houston you you have to
like
that's right that's right um so i like
technology and progress don't get me
wrong um
the challenge is is in the in the last
50 to 100 years 200 years we have become
so obsessed with solving for comfort
that we've pathologized discomfort we've
made discomfort the enemy and we have
some very real physiological things like
sadness and frustration and boredom and
anxiety
natural things that our body does that
we've said whoa whoa that's
uncomfortable we need to solve for that
and so if you think about anxiety as an
alarm in your kitchen it's just a smoke
detector letting you know your house is
on fire
you can go see a psychiatrist and climb
up in there and take the batteries out
which is what meds do
and the alarm will stop like i'll shut
that sucker off the house is still
burning down around you
or i can get a pillow and climb up on a
ladder and duct tape around that sucker
which is what addiction does right
that's what buying new things that's
what a new job title it's a pornography
it's all the things that's what what
another drink another drink or another
boyfriend and another or whatever that's
what that will do for you it'll help
gnome that sound out it will dim the
sound
but man if you're anxious going back to
the original question if you got
crippling anxiety
get with somebody and walk out to your
front yard and look at your house and
see what's on fire right and that's
where you start to heal anxiety it's
like duct taping over the
your gas gauge on your car why would you
do that right that's not the problem
it's just letting you know you need some
gas in the car right yeah and so i've
started making peace with anxiety and so
i'm an anxious guy i'm a super anxious
guy and mine's crippling when it comes
it's hard to walk out and so when i feel
it coming i begin to be curious with my
body what are you trying to protect me
from and it's a totally different
engagement with my body than the decade
i went to war against my body trying to
shut it up yeah yeah i'm this i'm the
same way i uh
i actually do experience anxiety pretty
easily um
that's why i did have a drug and alcohol
problem when i was you know from a
from a teenager until you know i was
like 28 29 years old
um well it's funny you know just talking
about the stories we tell ourselves
so i had this really cool uncle who um
told me all about these awesome
grateful dead shows he went to and you
know all the drugs that he was doing and
i really looked up to him
and the story i told myself is like i'm
gonna be my cool uncle
so i uh yeah very quickly started to um
yeah just experiment with different
drugs but then i realized that oh wow
like these drugs actually do kind of
shove down this anxiety yeah they work
that's the thing they work yeah and you
know what's crazy is like i was at a
point where
i would tell myself
people don't want to be around me unless
i unless i'm on drugs because that's the
only time that i can be myself and you
know other than that um people probably
don't want to be around me so there's
all these stories i was telling myself
and uh then i kind of had a look at um
my uncle's life and i'm like wait a
minute with this piece of his life
there's also this other piece that comes
with it and i'm like the whole iceberg
yeah right i'm like maybe i don't want
to be my my cool uncle um so the way i
would frame that is the story you were
born into was that's what cool is right
yes and over time what's so damning is
the stories we were born into the
stories we were told become the stories
we tell ourselves yeah and those are the
only stories we can challenge because i
can't i can't go back and edit what that
coach told me what that uncle told me
what that abuser told me i can't go back
and edit that the only control i have
moving forward is
what are these stories yeah and going
back to the uh fire alarm analogy we've
all been in that hotel room that the
smoke detector is so finely tuned that
you can be in a hot shower and it will
set it off right yeah there is moments
to go to psychiatrist and say i need to
take the batteries out just so i can go
sit with a counselor and actually hear
them right just so i can go back to my
wife and say dude i have not been the
guy you signed up for and i'm sorry
let's come back together there is
moments for that it's going back to what
you say it's it's not it won't fix it
long term it's not the ultimate solution
right no yeah absolutely so i eventually
went and got some professional help
and uh yeah i've just you know i've
probably had four or five like really
big
light bulb moments
in therapy but they have completely
helped me shift the story that i tell
myself and when it comes to anxiety i
still will feel anxiety um
i find that when my actions align with
my values i feel less anxiety
so i feel less and less anxiety these
days but when i do i kind of have done
the same thing that you've done like i
make this piece with it it's like i'll
sit with it and i'll really um examine
like okay where is this coming from did
i drink too much coffee this morning is
that gonna totally be it yeah yeah or is
there actually something wrong but
um learning to sit with it i think is is
a huge tool for crippling anxiety but to
get to that point yeah you might have to
go talk to a professional yeah to kind
of get a different you know different
perspective and that's what a good
therapist does i feel like what they do
is you tell them your story and they go
huh they're like why don't you look at
your story through this lens and how
does that feel yeah and so they they
just literally give you tools
to look at your story and shift it a
little bit and maybe start telling
yourself a different narrative and i'll
tell you i think modern psychotherapy
has failed us in the last hundred years
because it's become all cognitive
if you will just think about this thing
then you can think your way too and you
mentioned it a good count and there's a
there's a movement that's happening a
shift
go run up and down a hill five times
and your body will go all right we're
good you know what i mean yeah go call
somebody and say you're sorry go pay off
every debt you have and your alarm
system will stop ringing off the hook
because if you owe somebody else some
money that they control your next move
not you right if you have a job title
that you are
enslaved if you're in service to it
your body will tell you we're not okay
because every day we're going to work
doing stuff that we hate that's driving
our body crazy it's trying to trying to
get your attention so if you can circle
back and say dude what are you trying to
tell me man yeah like what is the goal
here and sometimes it's you got to pull
your kid out of 19 different activities
that you're trying to prop up your ego
with and
go kick a soccer ball in your front yard
together right go laugh a little bit
have joy in your life then your body
goes all right cool now now ryan's back
in the driver's seat i'm gonna turn the
alarm off right and i don't want to live
an anxiety free life that's that's the
alarm system is valuable it's good for
you yes it lets me know when i'm out of
balance and so the goal isn't to numb it
it's to make peace with it yeah you look
at anxiety as a symptom not not the
problem yeah it's a tool yeah it's a
dashboard yeah did you enjoy this
standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
slash the minimalists or click the link
in the description your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent
advertisement free